let's go next to
how about john from sacramento john
welcome
hey david can you hear me yes i can
so i think every david pakman's fan's
worst nightmare happened to me
last time i called in the mic didn't
work
i was panicking frantically trying to
get the buttons to work nothing did so
i'm elated that it works now i share in
the elation with you
so i'm an absolute political layman
but i had this crazy idea i wanted to
run by you just get your opinion please
so i looked at the second amendment
after you've all day i got really
depressed i was like man this is what
can we do yep and
i thought about the first part and i
thought and thought and thought
and so i was outside of dmv and i was
like that's it
what if we had a department of militia
regulation
and that department
said
okay we get to decide who can be in the
militia not i think uh level one he
could be hunter so any bolt action rifle
sure you're in the militia you can go
get that at your store oh you want to
move into level two well that's assault
rifles yeah 25 year old in the militia
and then we just set that up because
right now biden's uh not fulfilling his
constitutional obligation he's got to
have that regulated militia so i don't
know what are your thoughts on something
crazy like that listen you're thinking
too rationally and here's the reality
this the supreme court has found that
the second amendment applies to in an
individual right to have a firearm so
the focus on the militias
it's not actually
relevant unfortunately i mean i think
it's a great idea what you're saying i
think it should be applied just more
generally to gun safety regulations but
um no if you if you did exactly what
you're suggesting
the reaction would be to rightly say the
supreme court already found that there
is an individual right to a gun outside
of any militia we don't need to be
regulated as militias
do you think it would push
another case to the supreme court if you
tried to do that and there would be well
i guess with this court
i just don't think it would happen to be
told i don't want to bum you out john
but i just don't think it would go
anywhere uh
well but listen you're thinking of the
right things which are we need to take
control of the situation we just have to
find a way to do it legally
all right david i appreciate you taking
my call all right there is john
with a very important question
that we are going to continue looking
into